nice to meet you thank you
congratulations on your star thank you
it was a very moving day Hollywood Walk
of Fame
Canadian stars while you booked Canadian
yes right in front of the Mirvish
theater where I were I got my stew
almost got my star fur
do you have one star you prefer like
secretly there's a Walk of Fame in Idaho
look I love it's right it's one of the
service station that I know I this one
was very special because I as I said in
my speech I came here I didn't really
intend to leave Canada it was almost a
surprise to me when I made the move in
my 30s so the fact that I came here with
my wife that we we stuck it out and that
a big part of our journey has been this
this show when we go back to Canada
where we live in Vancouver part of the
time we will all know that I left
something here you know and I love I
love that so let's talk about Will &
Grace okay what's this to come I'm the
one that's the basic um yeah you're on
it it's really odd um so okay we'll
mmm-hmm like stepsister grace like I my
brain can't even really it's just like
what what's that like well what I love
is that it what does it change nothing
yeah but to them it just creeps them out
it's it's just not what I mean obviously
they're her father having sex with my
mother Jack and Karen bring that up a
lot just a part of others
but at the same time you know the
episode we finished the season with
blind Danner's feel free Borgess you and
robert client I led doors so in some
ways secretly I love the idea that
they're there together even though
they're not but but for us it's just it
makes us realize we're too close too
close would you say that your
relationship is unhealthy
I know they talked about it on the show
do you think it's unhealthy i alternate
li don't okay I ultimately don't it
would be unhealthy it's stopped us from
you know dating people from other
sitcoms but she's dating you know the
guy from friends so clearly that's okay
yes
and I'm gonna date that woman that ran
the airport from wings I think I I think
I'll do or the guy that was sitting the
big either who's sitting at the bar a
little Steve Ballmer Matt Bomer at this
chair steve-o steve-o no no skiers and
Matt Bomer is so funny in this episode
that we kind of went this has to happen
again so he'll be coming back I know you
guys talk about a lot of world issues
any topical storylines we can expect
this season we're doing one this week
this is really funny that Sean and I are
Jack and will go to Texas to see his
grandson in a talent show so we're
always said that already the two gay
guys in Texas this is good Karen comes
with us she goes to visit her section of
the wall because she's sponsored a
section of course which of course she
would so just that there's a lot of that
I think what we did with the bakeshop
last season was my favorite sort of way
of us being political I was funny to be
in the White House to start it but I
think when we're a little less overt and
more just about issues about that's the
best way for these four characters to to
say something but also stay funny you
know yeah and congratulations on season
three getting picked up crazy were you
anticipating diehard fans we just have
such an appetite for willing grace I
mean it was 20 years ago when guys first
one
well it's it's a combination right there
things are changing so fast there are
500 shows people been shows in a day and
a half so there's that happening and
it's somewhere in there you also just
want something to go fool
what can I rely on we leave to wake you
no I can't stand that I have to wait for
a week for John Oliver but I like that I
do because otherwise we'd all just keep
eating all the time I like horses but
hey we just keep eating into wheat fell
over so the fact that we just get to
week by week give them a little a little
more more willing grace and then it's
wonderful that to be part of someone's
plan every week that they bring their
family together I mean we're not
intended to be you know family show
great
it sure has and last question I have to
know is there anybody that you have on
your dream list as a guest our heart
desires Canadian yeah I think I think
we'll should have a secret fling with
Justin Trudeau I think you know I think
Justin might do it I know he's not gay
but I think I just think there would be
I just think we do is an arc where we'll
did will not reveal he's just say I'm
dating I'm dating a Canadian and then
we'll just have Justin come out of the
bedroom and go I gotta get back to work
watching of course he's watching course
of course the Prime Minister washes easy
Canada of course the dumb question